sit down it goes for three that's what
he's out there for yeah he's gotta be
that guy he's got to be in one of their
scores Brandon nice job of showing the
three-point shot easier it is for you to
get to the basket we did another look at
that last play by Brandon Ingram but
yeah but the threat of the outside shot
and players are always running at you a
plain tight so much easier it is for you
to get to the basket we get another look
at that last play by Brandon Ingram but
to pull up he shows you the basketball
and it makes it easier for you test it
strips here come the Lakers on the rod a
handful in the last three years look
kuzmin's way but he says I see you
Brandon and Brandon every sip you stall
last year 35 percent from distance and
he's really when you look at his numbers
though I look at Brandon he was hungry
and a bit on this up faking Brandon it
makes you pay they count the basket
give him a three-point opportunity in a
plate plating a point
steer point forward for this team when
you step back through the legs not
fighting back can't set up the way to
get another look at Brandon's face
enough with the Hagelin saying here take
this jumpers but the other I think it
was a lot of he was just a little
stronger and he was able to a bullet
contact and still be able to convert
some of the time flailing his arms he
just couldn't absorb it and that type of
good defensive play by Brandon and you
have more on now head to the Great
Northwest and after the games
Brandon a drum he bullies his way in and
scores he's still up now the middle he
goes through a power slam
[Applause]
Williams doesn't want bingum probably
does here he goes all the way start
and it moves out a 27-point can rebound
night behind-the-back works into the
land little jump shot the Lakers have it
back by one
[Applause]
it's all over this out-of-bounds play
this time it uses his right hand to free
it up and then gets filed by Gabriel
[Applause]